I want to make a few clarifications on
the video on the marriage penalty the
first is to point out a minor arithmetic
error is that when I calculated the
amount of taxes to pay on this bracket
so the 15% of the increment between
seventeen thousand eight fifty and
seventy two thousand five hundred that
is actually eight thousand one hundred
and ninety eight and since that was
eight thousand one hundred ninety eight
this right over here would have been ten
dollars higher so it's forty three
thousand four hundred and sixty six
doesn't change at all the ideas it's
actually a small amount of money in the
whole context of things but I just
wanted to get the math a little bit more
correct but you still see that you have
a marriage penalty but the more
important thing that I want to clarify
is I saw in the discussion on the
marriage penalty videos some people
saying okay fine if it costs more to
file married jointly well why don't
those people just opt to file as
individuals and then they're just have
to pay this right over here and then
they could essentially opt out of the
marriage penalty and I want to clarify
is that that is not an option if you are
married you don't use the pure
individual tax schedule you don't use
this over here instead if you are
married but you want to file separate
you use the married filing separate tax
schedule and you see in this that this
is this is exactly it's different it's
the same as the individual tax schedule
up until in these first three brackets
but then as we go above that bracket it
gets into the higher tax rates faster
than the individual ones and it does it
if you look at these brackets here you
see that they are exactly half the
brackets of the married filing jointly
and that's because at least for this
couple right over here that's making
identical incomes they are going to pay
the exact same amount taking into
account some roundoff error for married
filing separate as they are married
filing jointly and we can go through
that exercise so each of them had a
hundred thousand and taxable income and
that in couple a example that I gave and
so the first ten per state thousand nine
hundred twenty-five they're going to pay
ten percent that's just rounding that's
eight hundred and ninety 893 actually I
could even say eight hundred ninety two
point five if I want eight hundred
ninety two point five is ten percent of
that then on the next bracket they're
going to pay fifteen percent so that is
four
four thousand nine nine dollars and then
on the next bracket they're going to pay
twenty five percent so 25 percent of
this right over here actually I think I
rounded this number but will will take
into consideration a little roundoff
error so nine thousand two hundred and
thirty-eight and then they're going to
pay twenty eight percent twenty eight
percent on the increment the increment
above seventy three thousand two hundred
so they each have a hundred thousand one
two three and taxable income subtract
seventy three thousand two hundred from
that then they're paying twenty eight
percent on it and this gets us each of
them having to spend twenty or have to
pay twenty one thousand seven hundred
thirty three point five in taxes if we
combine the two for both parties to the
couple we have forty-three thousand four
hundred and sixty-seven forty-three
thousand four hundred and sixty-seven
which is essentially the same as they
would have had to file jointly the
difference between the six and the Seven
that's just because of some of the
roundoff right over here but they have
to pay the functionally equivalent tax
rate so just to be clear if you are
married you either have to do married
filing jointly married filing separate
there's also a separate head of
household but you do not have the option
of filing under an individual so you
can't just opt out of the marriage
penalty if it happens to exist for the
the scenario that that you happen to
fall into